there's a lot of people in this class
that think other people in this class
are cute they should go out and roll up
on them and ask them out and when they
say no that's good
we created a culture in the last 30 40
years where we tried to over protect
people from failure when I hear that
question from you I get scared because
when I think about the school system
Society for the last 30 40 years
we didn't do a lot of favors for people
to get comfortable with losing we
demonized it we by over protecting
people from it we made them think it was
bad the answer to the question is you
start practice losing here's a good one
there's a lot of people in this class
that think other people in this class
are cute they should go out and roll up
on them and ask them out and when they
say no that's good
humans not gen Z not emerging gen Alpha
not Boomers like humans need to practice
losing a lot more